du coup
[Musique]
m
trente ans trente années pour enfants
organisé un référendum
d'autodétermination en nouvelle
calédonie le 4 novembre 2018 les
électeurs doivent répondre à une
question simple voulez vous que la
nouvelle calédonie accède à la pleine
souveraineté et deviennent indépendantes
la mobilisation est à la hauteur de
l'enjeu et de la tante 81 % des
électeurs se sont déplacés pour voter
[Musique]
suffrages exprimés 138 1933 ont obtenu
pour le oui soixante mille cinq cent
soixante treize pour le nom 78000 360
le résultat est bien plus serré que
prévu le non à l'indépendance que
l'emportent avec près de 57% des voix
bien loin des 70 % que les sondages
avaient annoncé un soulagement tout de
même pour les partisans du maintien dans
la république
[Applaudissements]
mais avec 43% des suffrages
les indépendantistes créé la surprise
une défaite au goût de victoire pour
certains qui leur laisse l'espoir de
réaliser un jour leur rêve de quitter le
giron français
[Musique]
ce résultat serré laisse planer le doute
sur l'avenir du territoire pour
comprendre les problématiques de ce
petit coin de france au coeur du
pacifique
nous allons vous faire le récit d'une
campagne électorale et d'un scrutin
censé mettre fin à 30 années
d'incertitude
[Musique]
le caillou comme est surnommée la
nouvelle calédonie est un territoire
français depuis 1853 peuplée par les
kanaks depuis 3000 ans cet archipel du
pacifique
grand comme quatre départements français
compte 270 mille habitants et kanak mais
aussi des européens implantés depuis des
générations ou plus récemment et
également des populations venues
d'océanie ou d'asie un melting-pot
ancrés dans la société calédonienne mais
qui a aussi divisé le territoire entre
loyalistes défendant le maintien dans la
france et indépendantistes
principalement kanak qui veulent que le
territoire accède à la pleine
souveraineté
à quelques jours du scrutin décisif la
campagne bat son plein chaque camp réuni
ses soutiens organise des derniers
meetings tente de mobiliser les
électeurs
ce soir c'est la dernière réunion de
campagne à nouméa au siège du
rassemblement
merci organiser le mieux possible notre
représentant 7 contenant sept prochaines
consultations
pierre frogier le président du parti est
une figure du camp loyaliste sénateurs
les républicains de nouvelle calédonie
il veut que le nom à l'indépendant soit
massif est décisif
il s'agit de savoir si nous restons
français ou par an je veux vous dire ça
parce que ce jour-là le tac novembre
vous allez là toutes et tous
incarnez un carrelet ce que nous avons
fait depuis 30 ans je répète vous
incarnez ce choix binaire oui ou non à
la dépendance et donc oui ou non à la
france parce que le 5 novembre ce sera
un autre jour le 5 novembre ce sera un
autre jour
pour ma part j'espère que le nom à la
dépendance sera le plus significatif
il sera le plus clair sur le plus massif
de façon effectivement à construire à
reconstruire à réécrire une histoire
dans la france
à partir du 5 novembre pour pierre
frogier c'est l'aboutissement d'un
engagement d'une vie militant depuis 40
ans dans le camp loyaliste
il a été témoin et acteur de toute
l'histoire récente de l'archipel les
événements des années 80 une quasi
guerre civile où les affrontements ont
fait près de 100 morts en 1988
la prise d'otages d'ouvéa et l'assaut
donné en pleine présidentielle en seront
les pilotes les leaders des deux camps
finissent par enterrer la hache de
guerre
jean marie tjibaou pour les
indépendantistes jacques lafleur pour
les loyalistes se donne une poignée de
main historique et celle avec michel
rocard les accords de matignon
offrant à l'archipel disons de répit
avant un vote sur l'indépendance
même si pour les militants c'est un peu
de têtes dans l'immédiat parce que
l'avenir sera reconnaître que ces
accords ont constitué un pas important
en 1998 l'accord de nouméa repousse ce
référendum
finalement organisé en 2018 la nouvelle
calédonie dispose depuis d'un
gouvernement et d'un congrès qui peut
voter des lois propres au territoire une
autonomie très large unique dans la
république française
[Musique]
comme pierre frogier roch wamytan a été
un des acteurs de ces trente dernières
années
il est lui aussi signataire des accords
de nouméa en 1998 pour le camp
indépendantiste
un camp qui s'affichent unis pour ce
référendum
aujourd'hui c'est l'un des derniers
meetings au mont d'or dans la périphérie
de nouméa
l'événement fait la part belle aux
traditions kanak et à ses côtés roch
wamytan peut compter sur le soutien
d'autres indépendantistes notamment
oscar temaru venu spécialement de
polynésie pour soutenir les partisans du
oui
pour roch wamytan après trente ans de
transition
l'heure est venue de concrétiser le rêve
de l'indépendance
[Musique]
l'accession des prix à sa peine ne
permet tait ne faut pas croire tous ces
oiseaux là qui sont là depuis quelque
temps pour dire oui on va partir pour 25
on va faire pour 20 30 ans il n'y aura
pas le prendre le deuxième
ces lignes depuis 30 ans la culture et
l'identité kanak ont été reconnus et
développer mais cela reste insuffisant
pour lui une page doit désormais se
tourner hors de la tutelle française
nous considérons nous en tant
qu'indépendant disent que nous sommes
arrivés à la fin d'un cycle de notre
histoire dans des sorts calédonienne
commencé il ya déjà 165 ans et il nous
faut maintenant à partir du 4 novembre
dans un sens ou dans un autre
comme on dit fermez la parenthèse de
l'histoire de la colonisation française
en or et dont l'identité camatte
elle a été malmenée elle a explosé sur
le coup de boutoir de 6,1 points
d'avancé il faut arrêter ce système pour
l'emmener à foncer pour pouvoir sauver
des données vers amman
[Musique]
en nouvelle calédonie la division
territoriale entre kanaks et les autres
est frappante
la province sud est majoritairement
peuplé par les européens alors que la
province nord et les îles loyauté sont
principalement habitée par les kanaks
mais dans les territoires du nord tous
les kanak ne sont pas pour autant
indépendantiste
[Musique]
gérard poadja est un de ceux qui ont
fait le choix de la france sénateur de
la nouvelle calédonie depuis 2010 est
son engagement pour la république
il le tient de son père qui était grand
chef du district de poing dans un rôle
très important dans la coutume kanak
moi ce que je souhaite surtout ceux que
l'on abandonne ce clivage que j'en a
toujours l'habitude de croire et
particulièrement en france c'est de nous
faire croire en permanence que dès lors
que tu es kanak tué automatiquement un
journaliste dès lors que tu es d'origine
européenne lorenzo notice or des deux
côtés nous avons aussi bien des
indépendantistes ou des robins des bois
nordiste goudé faire ce choix de la
france n'a pas toujours été facile
surtout pour les kanak installée dans le
nord
les événements des années 80 ont
durablement marqué gérard poadja qui n'a
pourtant jamais quitté sa tribu
d'origine où il vit encore l'eau nos
cultures ont été saccagés
notre élevage
a été
on va dire
détruit comme ça ta mis que donc certes
c c c'est pas simple c'est pas facile
nous existons aujourd'hui son parti
qu'elle est denis ensemble est la
principale force politique de l'archipel
alors que la tournée des tribus se
termine chez lui à point dans le
sénateur vante le modèle calédonien
rattachée à la france mais avec de
grandes libertés locales une véritable
autonomie qui permet la reconnaissance
des spécificités calédonie bonjour du
branchement public avec nous non
seulement nous soutenir mais surtout
surtout nous accompagner développement
économique l'aménagement de la culture
puisque la république reconnaît ce que
nous sommes en tant que calédonien
pendant que kanak qu'ils acceptent aussi
notre culture notre culture notre
coutume est ce qui nous associer à tous
franchement je vous dis continuez à ce
que nous sommes aujourd'hui je me va
être difficile mais nous avons une
chance d'avoir la france avec nous
généralement ici l'ensemble de nos
tribus sont à 80 ou 90%
les mots nordiste non c'est la raison
pour laquelle il nous appartient aussi
de allait leur préciser notre projet au
projet politique dans la république
cette volonté de dialogue ne passe pas
partout heineken dans le nord est de la
grande terre
si les drapeaux français et kanak
cohabitent sur la mairie nous sommes
bien dans un bastion historique des
indépendantistes ou la période
d'affrontement des années 80 est encore
dans tous les esprits
ici sur la route menant à tiendanite le
5 décembre 1984 une embuscade étendu
pour abattre les leaders
indépendantistes qui sortait une réunion
bilan 10 morts dont deux frères de jean
marie tjibaou
[Musique]
bernard mahé pas c'est un des rares
survivants de la tacc sur les lieux du
drame
il témoigne inlassablement et moi je ne
suis pas mis les rescapés c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui je puisse te moyens et je
sais moi c'est un roi léon né à prendre
de le réhabiliter pas plus loin vous
aurez un musée où il a exposé les
témoignages et aussi les les photos et
tout ce qui s'est passé réellement passé
le l'événement à quelques kilomètres des
lieux de l'embuscade la tribu de
tiendanite est devenu un lieu de
tourisme mémoriel important jean marie
tjibaou leader de l'indépendance y est
enterré depuis 1989
à quelques mètres de sa sépulture
reposent les 10 de tiendanite comme on
appelle ces martyrs de la cause kanak
une façon on va pas oublier section
paris parce que je connais des larves et
poule où la dignité d'un peuple en
votant opposés à ce qu'ils ont fait pour
que au plus arriver au cap no 1 dans
cette tribu comme pour de nombreuses
communautés kanak la lutte pour
l'indépendance c'est encore bien vivace
le vivre ensemble est loin d'être une
réalité dans ces territoires plus
isolées très peu d'habitants d'origine
européenne sont installés ce qui ne
favorise pas la mixité sociale
nous on peut pas parler du vivre
ensemble qui en a pas chez nous c'est
clair et net
on est un croc parquet n'a qu'un but
voilà comment voulez vous qu'on parle de
vivre ensemble dessein commun
aujourd'hui le combat cessa c'est de
dire aux jec et aujourd'hui on peut
l'art alain privilégions de mots
l'objectif départ croître faux contenu
[Musique]
dont les plaines de l'ouest de la grande
terre les caldoches descendants de
bagnards ou d'immigrés européens sont
installés depuis des générations grands
propriétaires terriens
ils pratiquent l'élevage ou
l'agriculture jean-jacques de la thierry
vit et travaille avec les populations
autochtones des neiges perçage et plus
rien moi c'est ma vie c'est ma terre qui
tourne brusquement pris je venais ici
élevé ici de quatrième génération et je
me sens comme je viens de te dire aussi
bien en milieu mélanésiens communiaient
qu'au milieu fermé le polynésien et et
partout où je suis je suis à l'aise et
je suis heureux d'être toujours avec un
grand respect avec les interlocuteurs
qui sont face de moi
ici la population est davantage mélange
est une illustration de ce que les
accords de nouméa en 98 avait pris en
exemple pour dessiner le futur de la
nouvelle calédonie et qui avait été
résumé sous une formule construire un
destin commun le destin commun c'est le
sait le nom je découvre le commun a
toujours vécu on peut le donner
et puis on l'amélioré ma main je vois
maintenant ça va ça va enfin surtout en
bosses après à nous mais c'est sûr que
l'état décide c'est différent mais en
brousse on vit tous les jours en fin et
on est heureux du bon sens mais on est
heureux de partager ensemble aussi bien
le verre l'acier pour le coup de chance
le groupe pêche on est tous les jours
ensemble ici
[Musique]
rapprochement entre communautés qui se
construit patiemment et qui passe par la
connaissance de la culture kanak un
combat porté par jean marie tjibaou est
actée lors des accords de matignon en
1988 le centre culturel tjibaou a ouvert
ses portes dix ans plus tard
véritable joyau architectural conçu par
renzo piano
il oeuvre depuis maintenant 20 ans pour
la reconnaissance de la culture kanak et
pour une meilleure compréhension de
cette identité longtemps nos parents ils
ont appris nos ancêtres les gaulois
et puis bon là le 14 tout le programme
français et sans aucune référence à la
place de la calédonie dans le pacifique
le fait d'être mélanésiens d'être
enracinés depuis près de deux mille ans
ici et d'avoir 28 langues kanak et du
coup 28 potentialités de concevoir le
monde d'une manière différente quoi et
donc le propos c'était à partir de
quatre ravies de se dire il faut aussi
de changer le regard que non seulement
les cannas qu'ils ont sur eux mêmes mais
surtout que que les occidentaux grande
du sud les champs d'expression de cette
civilisation
trente ans après la fin des
affrontements
le centre culturel contribuer à un
rapprochement et une meilleure
compréhension des calédoniens
quelle que soit leur origine est le fils
de jean marie tjibaou espère que les
graines semées vont prospérer dans
l'avenir
j'espère que pour les 30 prochaines
années le propos il va être celui
d'inscrire cette notion de diversité
comme la règle et non plus comme une
exception
c'est ça mon espérance pour eux pour les
prochaines années et puis qu'on se
détache de cette notion de communauté ou
de couleur de peau c'est kanak c'est ça
veut dire comme hommes de ce pays c'est
ça le premier
la première notion qui somme toute
résume toutes les autres quoi
à quelques jours du scrutin décisif les
différents camps organisent leur dernier
meeting
[Musique]
pierre frogier organise une réunion
publique sur l'île des pins au coeur
d'une tribu le patron du rassemblement
mettant en garde sur les suites du
référendum
il ne digère pas l'impartialité affichée
par edouard philippe et emmanuel macron
dans cette campagne à 18 milles
kilomètres de paris moi j'ai pas
confiance
j'ai pas confiance ni dans le président
de la république ni dans le premier
ministre n'est pas confiance quand un
premier ministre n'est pas capable de
nous dire quel est son choix
quand il dit l'état impartial ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire quoi
ainsi alors les autres là ils sont
contents au rabais parce que c'est pour
passe c'est pour paquet de trouble c'est
pour pas chagriner les indépendantistes
et beau dire quoi ça alors nous on se
bat pour la france et puis on n'est pas
sûr que le président la république ou le
premier ministre ait envie qu'on reste
dans la france mais c'est quoi cette
salle
j'ai pas confiance en eux c'est pour ça
qu'il faut que le nom sur le plus grand
possible et à quelques jours du scrutin
certains que le nom va l'emporter
largement
le sénateur organise une conférence de
presse au siège du parti pour enfoncer
le clou
pour lui ce référendum doit mettre fin
définitivement la question de
l'indépendance
les deuxième et troisième scrutin qui
peuvent être organisés en 2020 et 2022
comme prévu par les accords de nouméa
non pour lui plus aucune raison d'être
lorsque nous aurons rejeté massivement
l'indépendance nous devrons payer tout
d'abord à ce que ce résultat ne soit pas
confisqué et je considère qu'en
conséquence il ne servira à rien de
poser la même question par référendum
une deuxième et une troisième fois je
déposerai donc une proposition de loi
constitutionnelle de façon à écarter ces
référendums
une intervention qui va enflammer un peu
plus les débats juste avant le vote
décisif 4 novembre au matin les files
devant les bureaux de vote sont longues
très longues
la première surprise de ce référendum
vient de la mobilisation massive des
électeurs
une influence qui ne faiblira pas de la
journée faisant grimper la participation
à plus de 80%
déclare à 18 heures le vote est clos
le dépouillement tant attendu peut
commencer
non alors inscrit 595 votants 520 oui 59
points dans les sièges des partis les
résultats commencent à tomber au
rassemblement les premiers chiffres
surtout venu du sud sont très positifs
sollicité par les journalistes
pierre frogier croit alors encore à une
large victoire des choses sont bien
effectivement le résultat
à l'heure où l'on parlait mais
significatif
[Applaudissements]
mais les apparences sont trompeuses
toute la soirée le wii reprend des
couleurs
chez les indépendantistes on suit avec
attention cette remontée et on s'amuse
des déconvenues du camp d'en face au bar
apparemment ya pas de normes à ses fans
c'est non et des noms avaient tablé bay
mais il avait 10 avait ramené leur
gueule au début en disant qu'ils
allaient faire 77,30 la voie que nous
c'était même pas on n'aurait pas sait
pas trop ce n'est même pas à 23 heures
tout le monde s'arrête poursuivre
l'allocution du président de la
république en direct dans les journaux
de 13 heures en métropole
j'invite chacun se saisir des
responsabilités exceptionnellement large
reconnu aux instances locales pour
construire la nouvelle calédonie forte
de son histoire est tournée vers demain
[Musique]
mais là ça on voit pas un est à dire
demain donné sa bénédiction m
détachement il biaise continuellement
dans son langage
[Musique]
là ce soir ça change pas la nouvelle
calédonie se réveille le lendemain avec
une véritable fracture territoriale
alors que la province sud a massivement
voté non la province nord et les îles
loyauté ont fait le choix inverse
[Musique]
l'état français veut montrer son
engagement dans le processus à venir
edouard philippe et donc sur place dès
le lundi pour consulter toutes les
forces politiques du territoire premier
reçu les élus de calédonie ensemble et
pour gérard poadja il est urgent de se
remettre autour de la table pour éviter
de réveiller les tensions
c'est un certainement un moteur
identitaire il faut aussi quand on se
rend compte que depuis 40 ans les
indépendantistes attendait leur fallait
donc c'est normal que on arrive dans
cette situation-là j'attire l'attention
et
des responsables que nous sommes éviter
de de diviser ce clivage parce que il ne
faut surtout pas qu'on tombe sur un
problème était les élus du fln caisses
sont eux très souriant après leurs bons
résultats et se projette déjà sur la
suite
avec l'indépendance toujours en ligne de
mire réjoui
nous avons échangé sur les résultats de
ce référendum qui non satisfait
évidemment puisque ça vient contredire
les pronostics
un des fameux sondages le travail
continue parce que s'ouvre la deuxième
période il y avait encore du deuxième
référendum qui se profile à l'horizon et
nous en avons parlé avec le premier
ministre
parce que nous sommes persuadés au vu de
ces résultats que le projet politique
porté par le fn ks devient quelque chose
de possible une lecture évidemment bien
différente pour pierre frogier qui
malgré la déception d'un score serré
estime que le débat est tranché
il maintient sa proposition de loi pour
supprimer les deuxième et troisième
référendum ce que je craignais apparaît
c'est que ce référendum n'a rien résolu
sauf effectivement le fait que la
calédonie est maintenant ancré dans la
france et que là le message qui nous est
donnée par la majorité des calédoniens
c'est un scribe est notre avenir dans la
république française
voilà
hier la nouvelle calédonie a voté
edouard finit pas bien entendu toutes
les positions
mais le premier ministre ne s'engage pas
encore sur la suite
convoquant pour décembre à paris une
réunion de l'ensemble des forces
politiques
tout indique que la nouvelle calédonie
devra revenir aux urnes en 2020 et
éventuellement 2022
le 4 novembre 2018 pourrait n'être
qu'une étape dans la grande histoire de
la nouvelle calédonie dont l'avenir est
encore à écrire pour l'instant au sein
de la république française
[Musique]